well Babylon 5 fans we finally know what
he's been teasing J Michael strasinski
of an abbreviated as JMS has been
teasing for a little while something
Babylon 5 related we've seen a logo but
we didn't know was it a reboot was it a
continuation what was it we were going
to get well now we know JMS has
confirmed that it is going to be an
original animated film this will not be
the first movie that will be set in
Babylon 5's uh timeline story in
Universe there were actually a few that
came out after the show was ended this
will be the first time it's being done
animated now we don't have a title we
don't have a lot we don't have plot
details we don't know what characters
are going to be involved since it is
animated it does have the potential for
actors to come back to voice their
characters where if they were to try and
appear in person they wouldn't fit the
timeline that if this is set during the
events of the show because the actors
would have aged out but there's
potential to that or even sound alike
for some of the actors who passed away
that's all uh supposition on my part he
is saying that the movie's basically
already finished and that a uh more
details including release will be
announced within a week